hey thank you for coming to my talk so
let's just get started so as you can
probably already tell from my outfit I
really really like to build fun things
with LEDs but I really didn't know that
I like to build fun things with LEDs
until recently
I built I've built things like this for
my this is my one of my dogs and despite
his like cool demeanor he's actually
like very pumped when he gets his
rainbow collar on cuz he gets a lot of
attention um so I guess I'd I haven't
been working with hardware that long
it's only for about the past year and
and I didn't get into Harbor because I
had some like really practical problem
to solve I got it for my free time that
doesn't really appeal to me I like
impractical things and whimsy and just
doing things for fun and I really got
inspired when I visited an Art Museum in
Amsterdam so this is a said oh look
Museum it's a Contemporary Art Museum in
Amsterdam and I went to see an art
exhibit by an artist called jean
tinguely and if you've never heard of
him he's a Swiss artist from the 60s and
70s and for him art is not about
standing in a sterile white space and
distantly gazing at a silent painting
artist meant to be playful and he
created these installations that were
meant to be triggered by a viewer so it
was meant to incorporate the viewers
experience into the overall effects of
the work of art and it was meant to
intentionally blur the line between
artists and viewer so he made several
art installations like this where you
could pick a writing utensil a pencil or
a pen put it into the art piece and you
trigger it and it would create an
entirely new work of art itself so it
was no longer about just watching a
process by choosing a drawing tool the
viewer plays a crucial role in the
creation of an entirely new piece of art
and when I was at the exhibit this quote
by him really stood out to me it says I
wanted
thing ephemeral that would pass like a
falling star the work just had to
transpire make people dream and talk and
that would be all and this just really
stood out to me I really like this idea
of art as this temporary experience that
connects the artists and viewer and it
just creates kind of this intimate
moment which between strangers and it's
just spontaneous it only is meant to
bring joy and aspire and it only lasts
for a short amount of time um so that
got me thinking I was very excited by
all these ideas and things I had seen at
the Art Museum and I really wanted to
figure out how I could use my skill set
as a developer and make my own
interactive art experience but unlike
John tingly I'm not an established
artist I wouldn't consider myself an
artist and I didn't have like access to
a studio space I live in a really tiny
studio apartment in Amsterdam so space
is very limited I don't have a place to
create and exhibit something so I
started thinking about how I could apply
this idea to something that's really
accessible and for me that was my
clothing so as you can see this is my
outfit and this is a meowt and Amsterdam
and then every is all I wanted to make
what was really important to me was to
make a really cohesive look I didn't
just want to throw some LEDs on a shirt
I wanted to create something that was
coordinated and would look like a
complete outfits um so as I started out
I as a web developer first thought about
the web app so I wanted to create some
kind of web app that usually could pick
colors and programs and then send it to
my clothes the next step which was
really the stuff that had the most
anxiety for me was actually building the
hardware into clothing I had done some
small little projects by following
tutorials but I had never done anything
like this before and picking out the
different pieces of hardware and like
really orchestrating everything together
and then the last piece of the puzzle
would be actually sending those messages
from the web app to the LEDs
in my clothing and for that I used a
library that I'm a huge fan of called
socket IO I've used it am I just
front-end web development career so it's
just in this one of my favorite
libraries so it's just a vent based
messaging it works in every browser on
every device and it's pretty simple to
set up so I was confident that I my
billet e to set this up so I had this
great plan I was super organized I
thought everything was gonna be really
really easy but as you can probably
guess I it wasn't
otherwise I wouldn't put that slide in I
faced a lot of challenges at first I
thought most of my challengers were
going to come from like wiring and
soldering because it was just like the
most ambitious project that I have taken
on but you know even though I had
setbacks that during the process that
made me question my abilities and I felt
frustrated that you know I just wasn't
ever gonna really get good good at
soldering and like figuring this stuff
out I just I tried not to let those
setbacks keep me down and you know
really building stuff whether it's
hardware or software is really about
building iteration just improving on
what you built um so let's just sort of
the beginning so like I showed in a
earlier size so I had this this was just
kind of the diagram this was my roadmap
for my project so I would just have a
web app and socket IO server and just
deploy that using node and Express on
Heroku and then I would have my three
pieces of clothing my umbrella and
necklace and skirt and those would just
be socket IO clients and really my main
focus I wasn't really focused saying too
much on the software so I'm gonna not
speak too much about that right now
and mainly just focus on the hardware
because that was my biggest obstacle so
hardware I needed to figure out how I
was going to control the LEDs in my
clothing and I had a couple of
requirements so it needed to be small it
needs to be discreet so it would just
kind of fit into my clothing and not
look bulky and I wouldn't have to wear
like a fanny pack or something
that really just wouldn't fit in with my
outfits it needs to be durable so since
this is clothing I'm gonna be taking it
on and off I wanted it to last so I
could wear it many many times and my
last criteria was I needed Wi-Fi
connectivity because this is how I
envisioned that I would be able to
connect my the hardware to receive
messages so I was just cool I'm just
tethering off my phone's Wi-Fi hotspot
so in my case I chose that Adafruit
feather huzzah
it's an Adreno and I chose an Adreno
because my garden trailers are really
great for projects like this it's if
you're not familiar with like the
difference between Adreno and Raspberry
Pi you know just kind of runs a loop and
it's really great when you just have one
a program to run and it can be
intermittently interrupted and updates
kind of it states through that but it's
just continually just running a loop and
listening and other reason I oh sorry so
I chose the Adafruit because it's an
Adreno it's small it has Wi-Fi built in
and a big reason weathers people really
love this this microprocessor that uses
the S esp8266 so there's lots of
tutorials information so I just felt
pretty confident there was a lot of
information I could figure things out on
it so I started on the building phase
and if you've never worked on the
hardware you might be curious what that
looks like and this is what it looks
like it's not very glamorous in my case
because like I said I have a really tiny
apartment in Amsterdam so I don't really
have a workspace so it was mainly just
me sitting on a yoga mat on the floor
just soldering and testing and repeating
the process for just each of these
pieces and when I was ready to actually
go out in public with this I really
tried to think things through so I
didn't want to give
people I was interacting with too much
context so I just made up these cards
that I could hand without giving a lot
of context without having to speak a lot
to them where they could just go to the
web app and interact with it themselves
so I took it out and I took it out for
the first time a few months ago in
Amsterdam we have a lighted bike ride
which is a lot of fun people swap a
bunch of Christmas lights and things on
their bikes and it's just a lot of fun
and I was really really excited to take
it out but I want to show you a video
clip what happened when I took it out so
as you can see everything's running
really good and then my skirt goes green
and it's going green and it rebooted
itself as you can see it's on a
different program from the rest of my
outfit yeah my skirt kept crashing and
for the people that are around me that a
worn in tech they were just mesmerized
that this was happening and they could
go and control it but all I could see
was like oh oh crap my skirt keeps
crashing or my umbrella would crash and
I have to restart it and to me it was it
was really embarrassing because I I
guess see these Falls and I and I
thought I had built this really durable
thing but it was actually pretty fragile
so yeah I was I was embarrassed and
disappointed but I just took as an
opportunity to move on to iteration 2 or
how I try to make it crash less so what
this particular
audrina that I'm using you can when you
plug it into your computer via USB you
get kind of a monitor so you can do
statements like you would do in
JavaScript like console.log statements
and as a JavaScript developer that's
sometimes a lot of times how I can
quickly debug things so as you can see
with this sample from the log statements
is that it kept disconnecting and
reconnecting over and over again
so what the Drina was having trouble
keeping a steady connection with my
socket IO server
so it took a step back and I even though
I'm like a huge fan of socket IO it is
made for web applications communicating
over HTTP and it's geared for browsers
so maybe I didn't need that for an IOT
project and you know just because the
library is available even if it's a
library that you really enjoy maybe in
even if someone's created like I caught
another version of that for your text
that you're using it might not be the
best solution so I really just took a
step back here step back and thought
about again what I was up against when
I'm coding for hardware so when you're
coding for Hardware your resources are
really at a premium there's just only so
much memory and RAM that you're
allocated on these really tiny tiny
microcontrollers and since I wasn't
communicating between a browser and a
server for my hardware you know maybe I
didn't need that extra overhead for HTTP
and I really just needed to find the
bare minimum but so easy to implement
and understand messaging by very
possible and that's when I found out
about mqtt and MQTT is a machine to
machine IOT protocol it's actually what
Facebook uses for Facebook messenger to
deliver and sync messages and it's been
around awhile it was invented in 1999
when engineers needed a solution that
would allow for minimal battery loss and
minimal bandwidth when they were
connecting sensors from remote areas in
Africa over a really shoddy satellite
connection and I really could give a
whole talk about how amazing MQTT is but
I really just want to highlight some of
the things that really appealed to me
and made me want to do the switch so
it's based on a publish/subscribe
architecture so there's clients that you
can integrate like in my web app and
then the clothing and then there's a
broker and clients connect to this
broker and that mediates the
communication between all connected
devices
and when I what the really key part of
this archit architecture is is that when
I could device connects it can subscribe
to topics and then when another client
puts us a message that has that topic
the broker affords the message to any
clients that are subscribed to it and I
really like this architecture because
the publisher and the subscribers don't
need to know about each other they don't
have to run at the same time and
operations on both components are not
halted during the publishing receiving
of messages it's super super lightweight
so it's transported over tcp/ip it only
has a 2 by overhead and it's just they
meant to keep it this way they meant to
keep these package headers really small
and every bit in that packet it's just
carefully crafted to remove to reduce
the amount of data transmitted over the
network it means that in comparison to
other protocols like HTTP it doesn't
load the network with transfer of
information that's just necessary to
allow the protocol to run and then
having this small overhead is just
really ideal for IOT because it lowers
the amount of data that might be
transmitted over really constrained
networks another thing I really like is
the MQTT has a really short and readable
spec and it uses simple verbs to
describe actions basically there's five
verbs in MQTT connect/disconnect
publish/subscribe and ping so I was
really jazzed up about MQTT and I really
couldn't wait to switch out my socket IO
clients and server and use mqtt instead
so I started with the web app and for
implementing this in the browser there's
n QT tjs library and you can use it in
the browser and it's written in
JavaScript so you can use it a note in
the browser and so I think the code is
pretty
easy to follow and that's one reason I
really liked implementing this because
there's only really a few lines so I
just require the library and then I
create a client that connects to the URL
wherever in the Internet I have my
broker Connect created and then in this
example if I have like a rainbow but and
that people can click on the change my
clothes so I just create a function so
whenever that button is clicked it sends
a message to the broker with the topic
lights and that's what I would have my
clients my outfit clients to subscribe
to and and then it can just send the
payload string of rainbow next I set up
the clients on the Adreno
so this is even if you're not familiar
kind of with adreno C++ code is pretty
much the same as the other client so
they just include the library I tell
it's where the broker is located which
URL on the web where to find it and it
subscribes to the topic lights and then
whenever messages receive just this on
message message method is called and
then it can just interpret the message
sent and then figure out what program
Anisa to switch to so I had my clients
set up it was all going like pretty
smoothly and the next was I needed to
set the broker so everything could talk
to each other and just want to show this
slide again so like I mentioned before I
deployed everything just on one Express
server on Heroku and when I went to go
set up my broker even though I really
loved Heroku because it has a really
great CL CLI that's easy to use I found
out you don't have port access you can't
specify specific ports and for this MQTT
protocol the port that specified that
you need to use for communication is one
eight eight three so that was a slight
hiccup because I couldn't actually build
my own MQTT broker yeah so I couldn't I
didn't have access support I couldn't I
couldn't set this up but I was also not
quite ready to leave her okay
kind of just wanted to see if all this
stuff was going to actually work
together while before I actually moved
to a different service so I went looking
for an external MQTT broker service and
it turns out there's a bunch of them the
one I ended up choosing is called
shifter I oh it's just a IOT prototyping
platform I chose it cuz it's free and
it's pretty easy sub you just give your
email and you get a key and a token and
compared to other mqtt broker services
it doesn't seem to limit the number of
messages they can receive per minute
some of them do and you have to actually
pay if you receive more than a few
messages a minute so I tried it out and
it worked and it works like really
really well compared to my first attempt
but I was happy but I wasn't ecstatic
because here it was I was replying
relying on this small external broker
service and that really just wasn't
optimal for me because there's just a
lot of unknowns there's not I didn't
know that much about this company and I
wanted to make something really reliable
and I really felt to make it really
reliable I needed to have control over
it so as you can probably guess the next
thing I did was I decided to create my
own broker and I had to do that I had to
move from Heroku to digitalocean
which gave me a little bit of anxiety
just because I've not that's comfortable
or skilled yet in doing like dev Ops II
kind of stuff but it worked out so it's
a you shouldn't be scared of that if
you're thinking about it's moving to a
service like that so to build this I
used this broker library called ATS and
what I really liked about this library
is just besides being you know using
streams and just it's a really new
modern library is that the broker is an
embeddable and my it would be embeddable
my current express server that I was
using to serve my website so I would
really have minimal configuration change
so I was pretty happy I would have to
build a second server for just handling
these messages
so to implement them for the mqtt broker
i just include the library and create
the MQTT server an HTTP server because
like I said this was also serving my web
app I just specified the ports that each
of those need to listen to so for mqtt
is someone 83 and then my app was just
on 8080 and then at the bottom you can
see that and I think this is really cool
as well is I can add on so that the HTTP
HTTP server that's serving my website it
can have MQTT over WebSockets
capabilities so those messages coming
from my web app they're just served
using WebSockets from the HTTP server
and I was pretty excited because this
was working really good and I had
figured out a lot of things and I
conquered DevOps fears so I was pretty
excited the last thing I did because I
really wanted to make this rock-solid
which I hope in a few minutes that I
showed that it's rock-solid is that I
upgraded the microcontroller so I
decided to change to the Adafruit
feather in 0y5 and there's a couple
reasons for that so it has low power
management so I wanted to stretch as
much out of my battery life as I could
and the main reason was that it has a
separate Wi-Fi module so what that means
it doesn't have to yield all the time to
the Wi-Fi course since it's a separate
chip so you get full rein of the
processor and timing and it just means
you just have really high speed reliable
Wi-Fi that doesn't crash there is a
downside and the downside is that is
twice the cost of the other
microcontroller I was using so the
feather hisses around 18 euros and this
cost around 35 but that was a downside
that wasn't it was worth the extra cost
to get the reliability so it's demo time
so this is probably the biggest audience
that I've had that can interact with
this so I invite you to please go to
flashy lights dot NL and you can play
around with my web app and change my
perfect
you can change what it looks like I'll
just preference this with this is meant
to be like a one-on-one experience so it
might get a little glitchy with so many
people sending to it at the same time
but what the heck like let's go for it
so while you're playing around at flashy
law I saw you know I just want to leave
you kind of with my closing thoughts
that you might not be aware but I am a
super introvert and this was a really
weird experiment to do as an introvert I
am NOT one that you know attracting
attention and actively seeking people to
out to interact with me is completely
out of my comfort zone sorry but it was
also an experiment that really pushed me
to deal with my own reactions to those
interactions and I just really wanted to
see if I could bring like a momentary
joy and whimsy to strangers by giving
them free rein over my appearance and
really outside of our tech bubble this
is not an application this is an
application like this is not one that
most people have seen and experienced so
is really I also found that I was kind
of breaking stereotypes about tech with
strangers like they were kind of taken
aback when they realized that I had
built this and you could do these kind
of weird experiments with tech and kind
of question what you know what you can
build and who is capable building those
things in tech and I said thank you for
listening
I am I also build other fun things with
LEDs so if you're interested in seeing
those I'm terrible at blogging at things
but I post pictures on Twitter and later
tonight I made another piece that's not
interactive but it's still really really
cool that I want to wear tonight at the
party so if you see me say hi don't be
shy thank you
[Applause]